President Trump once again going after
the World Health Organization this time
over its handling of the pandemic Trump
accusing the organization of being
biased in favor of China
he's also threatening to cut off funding
permanently to the w-h-o if changes are
not made in 30 days here's the president
earlier today basically they have to
clean up their act they have to do a
better job they have to be much more
fair to other countries including the
United States so we're not going to be
involved with them anymore we'll do it a
separate way Dana I wanted to ask you as
long as there's no train in the
background what happens if there's
another unknown pathogen and I think
that's likely at some point is it a good
idea for the United States to not be a
player in the World Health Organization
well I think that the president is doing
something that he has done before like
you did with NATO which is using
America's incredible and extensive
influence to force change at an
organization in order to have the
credibility of the United States be able
to be there to help you I think that we
all know that it's important for us to
have public health information in a way
that we can share but obviously there
was something extremely wrong that
happened between the w-h-o and China's
communication in their communication
with the world and I think getting to
the bottom of that is a number one - I
don't think that the president is saying
you will never get American support
again he's saying you have 30 days to
come up with some substantive changes
and then we will continue to be a part
of it and if you don't want to do that I
think that's fine like we'll walk away
we'll try something else but I think
that he is just being smart and figuring
out a way to leverage the United States
as to China recently said or I think was
yesterday said that they would donate
two billion dollars to the efforts to
help developing nations around the world
well two billion dollars that's like one
1,000 of what we just already spent in
our own country to deal with coronavirus
so that's kind of like chump change
China so if you want to have influence
you're gonna have to pony up a lot more
than that starting with opening up your
labs and whatever else you have other
information to get information to people
in the United
dates and around the world because we do
have to protect ourselves from this we
know it will happen again history does
repeat itself happened a hundred years
ago we have to be prepared for the
future
judge Pierrot I think that Dana's right
the president may be making a strategic
move but it's also a political move in
the sense that I think he's pointing a
finger at China by pointing at the w-h-o
so politically it has power but in terms
of policy do you think it's a good move
giving to give China the leadership
position at the w-h-o I think that it is
a brilliant move I think it's time that
the w-h-o cleaned up his act I think
three hundred and sixteen thousand dead
people around the world as reason enough
for at least three hundred and sixteen
thousand reasons to pull American money
out of an organization that could have
helped us and could have prevented many
of these deaths let's make no mistake
this organization said that there was no
human unit to human transmission this
organization was being lauded or lauded
China for instances where they had
travel restrictions within their own
country that's crazy
Dana is right we have to leverage this
like we leverage NATO you're not going
to take our money put not only the
United States but the world at risk it's
time that if there's American money
there's truth and transparency behind it
and when Taiwan came out and said
there's human a human transmission and
and and China said absolutely not we
should have listened to them and the
President did so this is what this is
the way you know Jesse what okay thanks
judge so Jesse what happens if the next
pandemic comes out of Africa or a Latin
America who gives the United States the
data advice on how to deal with it if it
hits our shores he said that he wants to
reform it and if they're not going to be
reformed we'll form a new organization
but you know that one this is what I
don't like how the media frames us so I
read the new
times today and the New York Times says
Trump is doing this to deflect blame so
see what they're doing
Republicans are always deflecting blame
why is that because the media is always
blaming Republicans for everything right
so whenever a Republican does anything
that doesn't have anything to do with
the thing they're being blamed for at
that very moment they are deflecting
blame so like Barack Obama can go after
fox he can go after Putin he can go
after Islamophobia
he's never deflecting blame only
Republicans can do it they do that with
also the word distraction right so Trump
is distracting from the pandemic by
going after the w-h-o no actually the
media wants everybody to focus on one
thing and Trump is just holding multiple
people accountable that's the game they
play I see well Gregg you know it seems
to me the Center for Disease Control the
CDC has been asking for more money so
you think they want a more robust
international presence for themselves do
you think maybe if we take money away
from the whu-oh we would give it to the
CDC I don't know maybe I mean the CDC
everybody was wrong and I think cut part
of the coming battle is gonna be the
experts who told us what was supposed to
be in our best interest and then the
rest of the world who found out they
weren't telling the truth I agree with
everything that's been said about NATO
and the World Health Organization
America first which I you know I you
know I was critical and now I realized
that it has some benefits and if you
believe in the America first way when
somebody screws with you you have a
president that goes out there and
settles the score so he's gonna settle
the score with a w-h-o the way he
settled the score with NATO and he's
probably gonna have to settle the score
with China because even though it wasn't
their fault when the virus came out they
covered it up we got to settle that
score oh yeah all right